Nevada State Police monitored thousands
of drivers on our roads like the one
behind me here every day and that's
especially tricky in the nation's worst
city for drunk driving that's according
to information from the FBI but with not
enough Troopers to keep up officials say
their operation is breaking
we just can't sustain what we're doing
right now it's a story Wayne dice has
told for years
the demand for state police patrol but
not enough staff to do it we should have
about 120 Troopers work in the valley 24
7. I think we're under 60. the Nevada
police union representative saying 112
members have left in just 2022 alone 12
to 14 Troopers needed for a fully
staffed shift this past Saturday only
four Troopers for the day shift the
previous Friday and Saturday only four
Troopers for East Schiff all day that
scene now all too common that they've
talked about limiting at graveyard shift
just because we don't have enough people
to fill those vacancies the department
operating with less than half of a full
team the state's website shows 65
positions unfilled as of Monday response
times reaching up to 40 minutes nearly
doubling the 2020 average dice says the
amount of DUIs crashes and fatalities on
Valley Road also Rising it's not even
safe for the public it's not even safe
for the Troopers because we just don't
have enough bodies to back each other up
it's kind of unnerving drivers like
Eleanor Oliver now thinking twice before
getting behind the wheel for their own
safety nobody ever thinks about
themselves getting in a situation where
they need help
until it happens
now because of those smaller Staffing
amounts and the larger call volumes he
adds that they've begun prioritizing
which calls they can respond to and it's
not all of them reporting live at the
I-15 at Desert Inn Brian Matthey a news
now